October for a lot of you it's a month
when things get colder the Sun starts
setting earlier and the kids all go out
trick-or-treating for the gaming crowd
it's a month full of anticipated game
releases and all sorts of announcements
so let's take a look back at 10 of the
biggest craziest and spookiest news
stories from October number 10 Mario and
Pikachu together we're getting very
close to the release of Pokemon Sun and
Moon but if you absolutely must get your
hands on one of the collectible monsters
Nintendo and the pokemon company have
you covered they combine Pikachu and
Mario into a new character and because
coming up with names is hard they called
it Mario Pikachu but it's ridiculously
cute and you can get it as a plushy
keychain or trading card number nine
star wars battlefront ultimate edition I
know you Jedi fans are jonesing for more
Star Wars stuff and while we are getting
close to the release of rogue one the
best way to get your galactic fix is
still star wars battlefront the Ultimate
Edition hits xbox one ps4 and PC on
November eighteenth and it packs all of
the games DLC including the upcoming
rogue one tie in the force is strong
with this one and by strong I mean it'll
cost you 70 bucks number 8 Resident
Evil's big numbers October is the
perfect month for scary games but Capcom
has been dropping the latest Resident
Evil titles on to the market all year
long the release of six came out in
march five launched in june and four
landed in august altogether the trio
shipped 1.5 million units which ain't
too shabby for the games that people
either call the best or worst in the
series number 7 voice actors on strike
what do we want better pay when do we
want it two years ago the sag after
union represents several video game
voice actors who simply aren't happy
with the way things are going in the
industry two years of negotiations have
led to zero progress and so those voice
actors are now on strike they're
targeting 11 major publishers including
Activision EA
and Warner Brothers how this will
actually affect the games we play has
yet to be seen number six mercies new
catchphrase of course overwatch got a
bunch of Halloween skins and of course
mercies is a super awesome which outfit
the good doctor also appears in the
game's Halloween brawl where she revives
your opponent while saying my servants
never die overwatch fans like this so
much they petitioned to have her say it
in the main game cut to about 500 forum
posts later and director Jeff Kaplan
responded with a simple okay so if
you're using the witch skin mercy will
say her new catchphrase after a future
update number 5 stranger things as an
8-bit game if you haven't watched
stranger things on Netflix yet take care
of that then come back I'll wait but for
those of you who have seen it 8-bit
cinema imagine the series as an 8-bit
game the four-minute video runs through
all of the show's biggest moments like
stealing waffles watching the Christmas
lights and defeating the monster why
can't season to be here already number 4
Pokemon Sun and moons data mined demo
remember when I said the next Pokemon
game was almost out well you can play a
special demo on your 3ds right now and
some players have already dug through
the code to find a bunch of Pokemon that
weren't announced yet at the risk of
spoiling anything I'll just tell you
that data miner k fought exclaims there
are 800 Pokemon in the game and all of
that secret stuff can be found on their
YouTube channel number three Halloween
celebrations mercies which costume was
just one small part of all the halloween
stuff out there overwatch had its new
brawl in a ton of skins pokemon go got a
special event with extra ghost pokemon
the street fighter 5 roster got their
own Halloween costumes and Destiny's
festival of the Lost was in full swing
and that's just off the top of my head
we probably won't see that much seasonal
content again until the holidays kickoff
number 2 red dead redemption to his
trailer it's hard to name a developer as
beloved as rock star and it's hard to
name a more anticipated game than red
dead redemption to finally over six
years later we got the first official
trailer for the sequel and it told us
sickly nothing we saw some beautiful
woods and prairies and farm towns and we
heard a character who sounded a lot like
Dutch vanderland a big villain from the
first game red dead redemption 2 is
coming to Xbox one and ps4 and fall 2017
so we'll definitely be seeing more of
the game in the future number one the
Nintendo switch new merchandise new
content and new games are all fine and
dandy but nothing gets the gaming world
excited quite like a new console after
months of rumors and speculation the big
end finally announced the Nintendo
switch with a hip millennial filled
trailer the switch is a hybrid console
you can plug in and play on your big
shiny TV or take the tablet controller
with you on the go the trailer also
teased us with some new games like mario
kart 8 splatoon and what looks like a
new adventure for mario nintendo has a
big presentation planned for january so
we'll be seeing more of the switch very
soon these were the biggest stories of
last month but they're just a small part
of everything that happened to check up
on all the consoles games DLC and other
good stuff stick with GameSpot we've got
all the latest 24 hours a day 7 days a
week all year round